question est ce que le carbone 14 deux
dates et les dinosaures n'avait pas dit
qu'on le faisait plus d'accord d'accord
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
absence aujourd'hui consacré à la
datation au carbone 14
on croit savoir beaucoup de choses à
propos du carbone 14 est souvent bon
nombre d'entre elles sont tout bonnement
fausses
par exemple si quelqu'un vous dit un
jour qu'il est possible de dater les
fossiles de dinosaures à l'aide du
carbone 14
alors soit il s'est trompé soit c'est un
menteur alors déjà le carbone 14
qu'est ce que c'est il s'agit d'un type
d'atomes de carbone naturellement
radioactif
c'est à dire que c'est une variante du
carbone normal mais qui se désintègre
spontanément en une forme plus stable et
plus courante de carbone le carbone 12
on dit que le carbone 14 et le carbone
12 sont des isotopes du carbone
j'ai dit des isotopes des visites cette
désintégration s'accompagne d'une
émission de photons c'est-à-dire de
particules de lumière d'où cette idée
très répandue que les éléments
radioactifs brillant noir comme le
carbone 14 n'en reste pas moins du
carbone cela veut dire qu'il est
naturellement présent dans tous les
tissus biologiques y compris votre corps
comme mais c'est pas la peine de faire
peur à tout le monde
rassurez vous ce n'est qu'en très faible
quantité rien du tout comparé à la
quantité de potassium 40 qui circulent
dans nos veines et que vous respirez
chaque seconde
mais tu dizaine mois à grimacer pas ma
faute si la radioactivité c'est un
phénomène naturel et spontané a lieu
partout et tout le temps bon cette
quantité de carbone 14 reste en
équilibre tant qu'un organisme est
vivant car sa désintégration est
compensé par le carbone 14 qui la gère
quand il se nourrit mais à sa mort il si
sedan intégrer hélas la quantité de
carbone 14 commence à diminuer au fur et
à mesure de sa désintégration la vitesse
de désintégration du carbone 14 est bien
connue déterminé à partir d'expériences
en laboratoire ils sont rentrés dans le
détail la vitesse de désintégration une
particule radioactive s'appelle la demi
vie c'est le temps qu'il faut à un
échantillon pour que 50% des matériaux
radioactifs il contient se désintègre
quelle que soit sa quantité initiale
rasoir au milieu au québec et ce qu'il
faut retenir
en gros si kenny thèse c'est une
distance exprimé sur un temps comme des
kilomètres par heure par exemple
pour le carbone 14 c'est pareil sa
vitesse de désintégration c'est le temps
qu'il lui faudra pour qu'une quantité à
2 carbone 14 se désintègre et devienne
une quantité b plus petit ce qu'il y ait
davantage de ses yeux comme nous l'avons
dit un peu plus tôt la quantité à du
carbone 14 et d'une constante et elle
est par définition la même si tous les
organismes vivants
donc si vous trouvez un jour un fossile
alors il vous suffira de mesurer la
quantité b2 carbone 14 qu'il contient et
qui sera d'autant plus petit que le
fossile sera anciens et le tour sera
joué
eurêka sachant la vitesse de
désintégration du carbone 14 est la
quantité de carbone 14 des intérêts rien
ne vous sera plus facile que de dire
depuis combien de temps votre fosse il
est resté enterré
un jeu d'enfant oui mais alors si c'est
si facile pourquoi par kronos est-ce que
cela poserait problème pour dater les
dinosaures
et bien c'est très simple la vitesse et
d intégration du carbone 14 est tout
bonnement rapide très rapide en fait
trop rapide avec une demi vie d'à peine
cinq mille sept cents ans on estime en
effet qu'en moins de cinquante mille ans
c'est à dire à peine un tout petit
vingtième de millions d'années la
quantité de carbone 14 devient si
infinitésimale qu'il est impossible de
la mesurer et en fait pour des
échantillons plus ancien que trente
mille ans la date donnée par le carbone
14 n'est tout simplement pas jugées
dignes de confiance
alors ce n'est certainement pas pour
l'appliquer sur un dinosaure vieux de
plus de 66 millions d'années ou alors
peut-être éventuellement sur ce type de
dinosaure à je le savais on nous ment on
nous spolie on nous fait prendre des
vessies pour des lanternes
il faut prendre le dernier des baladeurs
et hdtv on sait qu'elles ont ce cas
certes le carbone 14 est inadapté pour
dater les dinosaures
heureusement d'autres techniques de
datation existe pour des périodes plus
anciennes comme la méthode potassium
arbres et oui la méthode de datation des
crises plutôt consistant à se baser sur
le temps de désintégration d'un élément
radioactif en un autre est en théorie
applicable à n'importe quel élément
radioactif pas seulement au carbone 14
en pratique elle s'applique surtout à
quelques éléments radioactifs d'origine
magmatique
et cette fois pas biologique c'est le
cas par exemple du fameux potassium 40
qui se désintègre lentement en argot et
permet de dater des couches vieille de
quelques millions d'années à plusieurs
milliards d'années
encore faut-il avoir une couche de lave
à portée de main et la désintégration de
l'uranium en thorium puis en plomb qui a
encore plus lente permet quant à elle de
dattes et des roches vieilles de
plusieurs milliards d'années à condition
qu'elles contiennent du zircon c'est
ainsi qu'en 2014 la roche le plus ancien
de notre terre trouvait en australie a
été daté avec une grande précision de
4,3 174 milliards d'années ce qui
signifie que notre terre et ses tout
premiers christophe se sont refroidies
il ya environ 4,4 milliards d'années un
âge parfaitement cohérent avec celui
calculé par les planétologues et les
astrophysiciens à l'aide d'autres
méthodes totalement indépendante
ce cristal à lui seul prouve que notre
terre à au moins 4 5 milliards d'années
ce stade c'est terminé
si la martinique et surtout n'oubliez
pas le carbone 14 c'est bien mais pas
pour dater trop loin une annonce assez
nul bon ben qu'est ce que tu penses de
du carbone 14 dans la main ça à 50 mille
ans - c'est pas terrible non plus non
mais sinon j'ai attiré dater au carbone
c'est bien mais quand c'est pas trop
bien c'est mieux je suis plus révélateur
gpgp sinon on pourrait faire
datés ou conduire il faut choisir ou
bien encore pour dater les fossiles d'au
moins 50 millions choisi michael allen
avait perdu même c'est moins bon des
suppléments plus de 50000 jar binks
secours d'ath oui sinon tu penses quoi
de sophie et qu'elles brandissent est
une solution clé en main